I choose You Pikachu II and Conan the
Snowman it's episode 24 of IMG
cats can be painted to look like Pikachu
and so can girls she needs to put on
this contre sweater and here are
operating systems as Batman villains
Linux is the penguin Mac OS is two-faced
and windows as mr. freeze you don't have
to work hard to make Disney seem twisted
but Jeffrey Thomas did anyway Sleeping
Beauty Cinderella Snow White and jasmine
but where's waldo and better yet
where's kratos unreality mad compiled
kratos invading other games super mario
brothers three portal cataclysm do and
Angry Birds of course the stakes are
higher when the birds and pigs are your
children
Ray Charles Justin Bieber yeah Justin
Bieber on Facebook
Herman submitted delicious cookies
Paulina gave us the ultimate mutant Oreo
and mahmud cooked up a turtle murder
like us on Facebook to submit your own
and see more but here is a danger sign
hacked in real life and here's the
world's oldest video game gift break
when a semi drives under a bridge with a
bunch of snow on top you get this and
when you stack stacking chairs like a
ball you win portal comic makes female
versions of everything they're awesome
but I'm not sure how I feel about this
one and now people who look like their
dogs enjoy
food for the poor is a large charity but
check out about us leadership and the
president of food for the poor is I'm
not kidding robbing my food postal codes
in Canada are alphanumeric British
Columbia codes start with B and right
over here the postal code I kid you not
is yeah there's a park in Seattle named
after the old-fashioned saying
by cracky you've got it so the park is
called bike rack part final stickers and
a tanning booth gives you tan the man
but you can also be a Yankees fan sport
tiny wings the Mona Lisa or just suck
then cover that tan with an unfortunate
t-shirt monopoly maturity and whatever
this is
got some old NES controllers hanging
around will turn them into an iPhone
dock a computer mouse a wallet or a
doorbell the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles all grown up and a pair of
cheetara's but who would been in a fight
the Turtles or the Thundercats sounds
like a job for nerd wars and to see Jeff
and Adam Duke it out click here and
subscribe to our gamer to keep the
Vsauce family strong
Here I am along with Andre from black
nerd comedy and we've got Valentine's
Day today I hope you guys are all having
a romantic time but I've got a question
for you where do you think people get
the pink and red dyes that show up in
fruit juices strawberry yogurt and
makeup what do you think Todd Andre
where do you think we get all those red
dyes that we put in our bodies clothes
it comes from bugs that's right we dry
and crush up the carcasses of the
cochineal beetle and then pour that into
yogurts and juices and then we make it
look pretty but then we eat it and put
it on our faces so happy Valentine's Day
that was awkward
for more awkward this with a girl you
can check out one of my videos right
right there right where I'm pointing
that in the sky
butterfly in this